latest provocation from North Korea the
country's leadership says it tested a
new kind of intercontinental ballistic
missile one using solid fuel instead of
liquid which could make it quicker to
launch overnight the U.S and South Korea
apparently in a counter move conducted
joint air drills over the Korean
Peninsula including F-16 Fighters and a
B-52 bomber solid fuel missiles have
really been a key goal of North Korea
for a very long time and North Korean
State media did broadcast the launch of
that new missile set to Propaganda music
from an undisclosed location now these
kinds of missiles can be deployed faster
easier and also more safely a solid fuel
also doesn't degrade as fast that means
they can be fueled long before launch so
that means spy satellites might have a
tougher time detecting them